royal master so from canada
to for forty is
um i already had some games son
against him it's pretty pretty good
player
the nimso of course is is new
for games between us
because i usually go knight f3 but uh
i try to vary in my openings a bit
yeah we got um really the the classical
structure for for the nimto zamish
variation
known from back in the day
the botwinning capoblanca game from the
30s
since then this whole setup
someone has a bad reputation from from
black's point of view but
i guess it's not entirely justified if
he plays um
correctly
still it's very much out of fashion to
to play this way
but people um
rather often get in this position
without really
knowing what uh what they're up against
okay if i play e4 now
he maybe he's got some tricks with
picture with knight e5
maybe it's an idea to
prepare this a little bit more
the bishop on b2
makes a bit of a stupid impression but i
need to
use the rooks here on the open files
and also over protect the form
okay interesting
what about e4 now d takes f takes
knight takes e4 knight f5
is this something
maybe it's some premature
okay of course this
is two moves first rook d1 then e1 but
if we play e4 the queen is also opposite
the rook zone
he maybe needs to do something about
this
of course you can go just through d8
here
and then it's um
really interesting question can i play
e4 then or
yeah we have to take here
okay he he tries to
play on the on the light squares
of course i have to two drones in the
center
e5 now then you
maybe simply takes it
yeah but i can i can play knight f5
i think
i think this position is
very very dangerous for black
if not downright don't write bad
this looks like a huge attack coming
queen g3
so maybe simply rook f3
to get um queen h4
rook h3 going
this also keeps an eye on the rook on d8
so i guess um also knight g7 is a threat
now
one major issue is that the knights
don't really help
in defending at all sitting there pretty
but
don't have the king
rook h3 he just goes what
h6
looks terrible
the smells
still i don't see something
completely convincing
the idea of this move was to go
94 a queen e4
time warning
hmm
hmm
check check
yeah this wasn't convincing
check oh that was lucky
check
check check
check
check
i hate it just to lose on time
check white forfeits on time
from completely winning position this
attack was
unbelievable that it didn't
didn't get through
yeah at this point queen e4 computer
gives queenie forest winning
he tells me i think you were better i am
not not especially difficult to see
97 winning
check check check
queen b7 is just checkmate let's just
check mate
check my in in three moves
oh boy i didn't look at this direction
at all
this is also still winning
yeah maybe i didn't i didn't play
absolute best moves but it was
completely winning
just a matter of time i really should
win with 16 seconds in this position
yeah well next game